thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show open homes a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Christie Wright is joining me for a
couple of segments here talking about
ladies and business women in business
and starting their own thing or running
their own thing or doing their own
things some of them come home to be
stay-at-home moms and yet have
tremendous education Drive training
potential and want to do something with
that
some ladies come on to be stay-at-home
moms and just want to do that which is
perfectly fine but we want to give the
ladies that want to do something from
home to add to their family's top-line
add to their family's income for
whatever reason whether it's to hit some
goals like getting out of debt or
something else we want to give them some
tools to do that
Krissi's uh you know come along in our
small business area or leadership area
that we teach business coaching and
we've specialized this thing called
business boutique just for ladies
equipping women to make money doing what
they love and so whether it's the
marketing side the financial side the
hiring side the social media piece of
marketing the inspirational piece
talking some ladies that have been
unbelievably successful some that are
just starting their own dream moving it
from a hobby to a business all of this
is business boutique
it's November 6th and 7th in Nashville
it's a two-day event and you can learn
more at business boutique comm 199 a
person which is a deal and a lot of
people are a lot of our ladies went to
an event the other day they paid almost
that for a 3/4 day event that was not
nearly staffed as well as this is so
again triple 8 22 piece triple eight two
two seven three two two three this event
will be off the charts you do not want
to miss it ladies if you have an
interest in that area so very cool stuff
so one of the things that happens and we
talked about that a little bit before
the break is that some of these small
business ideas start as a hobby mm-hmm
how do you tell them to know
when when they're moving from a hobby
into a successful business if they
should or how they're doing it or at
what point we quit calling it aa B and
we need to just say what it is it's now
a business and so on I think first you
really have to ask yourself is this
something that I want to treat like a
business and that means that you're
going to treat it for the purpose of
making a profit now you're still serving
people but the difference between a
hobby and a business is that a hobby
costs you money and a business makes you
money and it seems really simple but a
lot of people not just women have
hobbies that they say they want to turn
into businesses but they keep treating
them like hobbies and they don't look at
their profit margin or any of their
financials and they're like well I just
love it that's all that matters and if
you want to turn this into a business
that's great but you've got to start
treating it like a business so the first
question would be to ask yourself do I
want to do that do I want to take this
thing that I love that I do right now
for fun as an outlet and have the
responsibility of treating it like a
business because if you want the
business to be successful you have to
treat it differently than you do as a
creative outlet so if you want to do
that then we can give you the steps to
do that and if you don't that's fine and
by the way you can make a profit I still
be creative right absolutely you can
still enjoy it so many people say well I
enjoy it so I felt guilty making money
as if for some reason you're not
supposed to enjoy the things that you do
for an income but but you can do that
you can enjoy it you can have fun many
of the women I talked to they say this
business and they're treating it like a
business they're successful with their
side business they say it is this outlet
for me that is one of the areas of my
life that I give to and it actually
gives back to me it actually gives me
energy versus depleting my energy so you
definitely can build a business that
still does those things for you but a
business will have additional
responsibilities of plans and financials
and record-keeping and and people that
you're accountable to whereas with a
hobby you don't have those things so you
really need to ask yourself if you're
ready to do that before you turn that
into a business I find myself in the
entree leadership material working with
men or women often almost reprimanding
someone who thinks they're running a
business but it's yet to make a profit
and always tell them this is a hobby
right and so it's kind of the other way
and you're in you're on one side of this
where are you the other side of this in
a sense where you're saying okay this is
a hobby let me show you how to make it a
business right rather than it's a
business is not cutting it right and if
you have a
be that you enjoy and you are able to
turn it into a business that you are
good with the amount of responsibility
how great is that because you're
combining something you love with making
money so you enjoy it and you're having
good time plus you're contributing to
your family income so it can be done and
it can be very very enjoyable but
there's a process you go through you
can't like you said you can't keep
treating like a hobby and not making
money because first of all your family
is going to be funding it so you're it
has serious implications to your family
budget
additionally especially for moms that
have all these responsibilities to the
household and family it's very difficult
to justify 20 or 30 or 40 hours a week
away from your family just because you
love it you know you need to have a
financial roi to say I'm spending this
time painting doing crafts teaching
lessons tutoring and I'm also have this
financial ROI to show for it
yeah so what are some examples of
hobbies that you have seen as you've
coached people on these things go into
legitimate businesses so that there's
two main common areas you get the
product side of things and a lot of
people start their product based
business on Etsy
so that would be crafts sewing clothes
you always use the example of the hair
bows when it became an incredibly
successful company t-shirts handbags all
of those products side of things and
then you have the service side of things
and that could be anything from walking
dogs to mowing lawns to teaching lessons
to doing transcription services here in
makeup art artists a lot of people with
professional education and experience
whether that's a graphic designer or
programmer things like that if they go
do freelance and build their own
business they're incredibly successful
because those services are in high
demand and they pay well if they build
the business right so you really have
those two sides of things very cool good
stuff now we talked a little bit about
fear before the break and it's a barrier
for everyone in business ladies too
the first step is the heart it's kind of
like a lot of things I guess when you
finally do step out there and and and
take the first step push through the
fear right the fear starts to dissipate
and the more steps you take the more you
guys you get confidence right and I've
noticed that just as an entrepreneur
myself but how are you coaching these
ladies to push through that fear what's
the key to doing that
I think one of the big myths around fear
is
if you have fear something's wrong it's
a red flag you shouldn't do it because
you're scared you've got to somehow get
over that fear before you can take steps
but just like you said taking the step
is actually what gets rid of the fear so
I'll use an example with me speaking on
stage what I encourage people to do is
just do it once you don't have to say
I'm going to commit to a career speaking
just walk on a stage once and once you
walk out there and you do the thing then
you have the confidence of I've done it
once I can do it again I didn't die from
it right exactly speaking thing people
think they're going about it does feel
like that sometimes but it's interesting
because if you can just do it once and I
tell people do it scared don't wait
until you're not scared to do the thing
you'll never do it just do it scared the
first time I walked on stage I was
scared and sometimes the second and
third times too but over time you look
back and go hey I've done it this many
times I've done these things I don't
have to be scared you have confidence of
experience to stand on but the first
time it is scary don't wait till you're
getting overcome the fear to do it just
do it scared do it anyway and then that
will make the fear dissipate just like
you said you know we've often everyone
has overused the metaphor of learning to
ride a bike but it's anytime you're
outside your comfort zone learning to do
something that's not going to kill you
right you know are not going to bring
you harm right and so you want to do it
scared but you don't want to do it
unwise and scared to where you know if
this doesn't work we bankrupt right we
don't do that right and so it's a it's a
baby step it's a small step but and what
we encourage folks to do is to take
positions that are if they fail it's a
non-fatal failure right and that reduces
the fear to where it's just an emotion
that's no longer a logical fear right
it's a logical fear that's telling you
not to touch a hot stove you want to
hear that one right now that tells you
don't step out in traffic you'll get run
over and so that's a logical fear but
the illogical fear that we all have on
man-woman new old entrepreneur whatever
it doesn't go away it just you learn to
control it and you learn to see it for
what it is and the way to beat that is
just do it anyway right and it's
interesting because a lot of times our
fears or a lot of the women I've spoken
to their fear is not around the plan the
business side of things their fears
around themselves what if I'm not good
enough what if I'm rejected what if we
what if I'm a failure and so it's a
large large it is it feels very
vulnerable so if you can help them over
that and then give them the tools to do
it wisely on the financial side and the
business side they've got both sides
that we need that they need very
interesting business boutique is the
event Christie right is the main speaker
Rachel Cruise Stephanie Parker cordilla
Arrington a whole lineup of top-flight
ladies in the business world there to
teach you about the different areas of
business learn about it at business
boutique comm are called triple a
22-piece triple eight two two seven
three two two three